it's a story that begins with a British
prince and a blind date with an American
actor their wedding day was everything a
modern fairytale needed but 20 months on
the story has changed and their future
is uncertain it's still not even clear
where they'll live Frogmore cottage will
remain a UK base but it's clear Canada
is their preferred home the Duchess
holed up in a remote mansion and the
couple contemplating a life in
self-imposed exile on this side of the
Atlantic it said they want to build a
global brand the Duke has already been
spotted touting his wife's acting
services to the boss of Disney bosses at
Netflix say they'd be open to talks with
the couple perhaps a deal along the
lines of the one struck by their friends
the Obamas even though they will do
worthy acts and continue with their
foundation they're still going to have
to own their own money and that's going
to involve doing some deals in you know
Los Angeles perhaps with Netflix perhaps
with fashion firm so there's always a
danger that that's going to look rather
tacky but from their point of view they
will still have to earn some money as
the Duke rejoins his wife here there are
big questions that Canadians have like
many other people will they apply for
official residency here will they try to
get work permits who will they pay their
taxes to and one other question that
really concerns Canadian taxpayers who
pays for the security as we saw when
they made their public debut together
protection is a fact of life for the
couple will Canada have to pick up the
tab the appreciation for Harry and Megan
would really stop at whether Canadians
have to pay whether taxpayers have to
foot the bill that's something that
polls have shown Canadians
overwhelmingly do not want there is a
petition that has been circulated by the
tax payer Federation talking about the
fact that Canadians shouldn't have to
foot the bill there have been leaders of
the and for instance a political party
that represents a lot of Quebecers in
the House of Commons has said that he's
also said that it's just not on that
Quebecers or Canadians should pay for
the security the payback may come in the
couple's charity work Canadians have had
a glimpse of the kind of work the
Duchess might do here
raising the profile of Canadian
organizations it is evident that is what
the couple want to focus on but for all
the distance history has shown that
separating a royal from the royal family
can be harder than it looks